I'm here with six-time Grand Slam winner
and one of the youngest to ever do it at
the Wimbledon Boris Becker a legend of
the sport
Boris welcome back to Bucharest tell us
about your first impressions here at the
Sahara Country Club at the venue the
playing hold the players because you've
met already some of them I'm a big fan
of Romania of Bucharest in particular
you know way back when I met mr. John
Terry Atkins family became embedded into
Romania so it's always good for me to
come back but I'm in particular proud to
be invited through the super bad
tournament here at stationary Country
Club
it's an illustrious group of
grandmasters I'm surrounded with I
played a quick game of chess with
Fabiana Caruso and I'm honored to be you
know promoting such an important
tournament I know you've played some of
the best chess players in the world the
Europe ended a lot of chess tournaments
white chess chess is very similar to
tennis it's a man against man not the
first move but the last ball counts you
need to be very patient a lot of
strategy a lot of mind games going on on
a chess board on a tennis court and
ultimately on your own you are
responsible for everything you do so
very similar lifestyles for similar
mentality and ever I met Gary Kasparov
twenty-five years ago I became a big fan
and I got to play with him as well don't
ask who won so I became a big fan of
chess we often hear a lot of the tennis
players take cues from chess players but
what can chess players take from tennis
players in terms of strategy in terms of
preparation psychological edge a thing
is always important to find your own
identity how you are what's your comfort
zone how you want to play because it's
always bad to adapt too much to do your
position your position has adapt to your
style and I think that's what the top
tennis players do so well and probably
the top chess players as well so whoever
wants to be good if to find your own
signature an important initiative of the
super bad foundation is to
bring chess to the younger generations
you yourself have taught your kids how
to play chess why do you think it's so
important teach them at a young age a
chess as tennis gives young people the
experience of learning a lot of life
skills about you know fair play about
patience about strategy about math
geometry all these things that you need
to so much later in life regardless
whether I become a professional or not
so the earlier you can start the better
you will be I know you've played the
Garrick Astra of Nigel short but who is
the strongest tennis player that you've
faced over the chessboard there are a
couple of good ones around I'd like to
think I'm one of the best tennis players
I don't remember a loss yet but then I
don't play every tournament but I
hopefully I can promote that in the
tennis circles as well we've had one of
the most memorable matches of tennis
this year at Wimbledon
when Novak Djokovic upset Roger Federer
how did you see that match from the
stands as a chess player very much so
one of the best matches of tennis I've
seen you know two players at their peak
playing their very best at the most
important tournament what more do you
want and I commentate it for five hours
on top of it but nobody is a big chess
player as well we played a lot of chess
together is very strategic on the court
he knows exactly which point to do with
what score and I think that's what makes
him win
you